voilà si un jour je voyais le président
quelle est la question que je poserai je
joue ici par julien courbet ouais tu
l'as acheté auto scooters ou valérie
bénaïm france
les prochaines mesures pour lutter
contre le chômage ah bon vous savez ça
n'a rien fait comme les autres
journalistes basse et des vraies
questions mais il faut lui poser
d'autres questions que personne ne pose
à bon iver wildfire comment va julie
gayet mois de mai soit aussi tout le
monde y pense
jean-michel non oui c est ce qu il va
l'épouser j'aimerais bien avoir un
mariage présidentielle au mali thierry
pas comment il va
ouais s'il n'a pas du tout jusque là
vous avez échoué pourquoi isabelle pas
de regret d'y être allé ouais ouais
et elle est la foule le président pas de
regret dit être allé et nohra pourquoi
toi aussi tu nous a menti
olemps et ouais ils sont ici dans ma foi
il déconnait pas du tout là et jean-luc
comment tu fais avec les meufs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bah oui
c'est vrai
enfin des rennais ou des maladresses
comme vous dites moi je passais moi je
ramènerai durée ni du maroc si j'y vais
un jour jouer avec et nous ça serait
quoi la question lui poseriez bras dans
ce conte mais j'aimerais bien lui poser
combien ça coûte à louer l'elysée ce
n'est pas ce qu'on veut faire une fête
avec nous tout public